okay I this is the second plaque in a
row what's going on
am I starting to whine I don't mind
playing black actually I think I
actually have a worse record playing the
white side and over the board games than
I do with the black so what can be said
about that I'm just gonna take care get
this paunch structure how I want it I'm
just learn some more with this and let's
establish pawns on dark my queen here
pawn up here what does that say if I'm
winning more games if I'm doing better
with black and I am with white it means
my opening knowledge is garbage
I should be definitely doing better with
white but that's not the case my
opponent is afraid of this what are they
afraid of they're afraid of a fork for
one thing and I could establish like in
the previous game I could establish a
pawn on e4 and well if you were here two
minutes ago you know things didn't turn
out that's so well but things are things
are much different such that I've given
up my dark square Bishop these ponds are
messed up and I could try and form a
structure where I restrict this Bishop
on c1 now how can I accomplish that I
think for starters this is good and my
follow up I believe should once again in
this instance be c5 now in that previous
game this pond was on b3 and this Bishop
once playing - b2 had direct sight we
eventually had dark square Bishop
exchange but I believe that this is
still the correct way to go
c5 just to make sure these guys don't
get rolling okay
and now I think I could jump into this
square but my only concern is do I first
throw my bishop
here and I believe I do so let's get him
out and working and as a follow-up well
is there really going to be a better
square than d7 we're gonna see about
that now my opponent could maybe give me
some problems and they are giving me
some problems okay they're trying to
undermine this pond and I believe that
they are successful so let's see
candidate moves pawn takes I really want
to be in a spot to recapture with my
knight because I don't know if I want to
give up my light-square bishop that's
one thing but as soon as pond takes the
rook is hitting my bishop so should I
move my bishop back this is my first
thought the second pot is to just take
because then maybe I can put pressure on
this pawn
I think I'm gonna take actually yeah let
me take so okay I think I still just
jump in here there's not going to be
anything better my bishop is unprotected
but if as soon as the knight moves I
just drop my bishop back I'm okay well
I'm going to have to be okay with giving
up my bishop if the knight insists on
getting to f5 he is I use this use this
word to describe the previous games
Knight d5 that that knight on d5 would
be intolerable and I believe that a
knight on f5 would also be intolerable
now I wonder if I should just drop back
to g6 so that if Bishop takes I
recapture with the pond and I need not
worry about the f5 Square or I could
just maybe post up on e4 or take and
then play 94 they they all look pretty
appealing I'm gonna go with this and
play my knight in here and if I need
more support I could definitely consider
f5 or just getting the last piece
working my rook on a to e8 any rook move
to the B file pretty much the knee-jerk
reaction is going to be this unless I
want to move my knight now I just want
to do this do I really want to devote my
Queen to the defense of a pond no I
don't
in fact my queen will be overloaded if
if that happened so I think I support my
knight here I do with this last move
have to be extremely careful about
allowing a night to get here
it's not so easy to to do there you
can't do that so easily so I'm looking
to simplify a bit more my opponent is
coming at me pretty hard I want to move
my knight but I guess I have to babysit
my pawn I don't want to take as this
rook just becomes very annoying on the
seventh rank so I'm also down on time
pawn takes I just recaptured the pawn I
want to play 95 can I get 95 in can I
also play faster okay
hang on hang on rook here trying to get
to the seventh
maybe I say no soup for you with this
the Bishop move I'm not sure what that's
doing I'm not afraid of that move this
was another reason by the way I
supported my knight with that five even
though it was supported with my queen I
wanted to make this 95 move available
can't recall if I pointed that out so I
definitely recaptured my Queen capturing
with my pawn just makes this pawn
connected it makes them past hitting at
this point twice potential for forks if
the Queen goes too far away what to do
about defending this pawn it's not fun
having to defend b6 I must say flight
squares my first thought let me just go
with it
throw the move back at my opponent I
don't I don't have all the answers in
this position I have all the answers so
sometimes you just have to move and say
hey you figure out what we should be
doing because I don't know what should
we be doing can somebody tell me I don't
know okay I should probably get my rook
doing something other than staring at a
pond that's you don't need to defend
that pawn anymore you just don't need to
defend that and what's unprotected this
guy so let's hit him this pawn is safe
twice he might be undermined though
maybe I should have addressed that
actually if the bishop moves
okay night here no longer comes with the
fork but maybe the queen is close to
being trapped actually I'd be setting
myself up for a tactic if I did
something like that so let's say no g48h
five says you won't play g4 successfully
to undermine my Knight and the reason I
said rook D is not a good option is
because of rook takes Knight this isn't
a threat because the pressure on the
bishop in fact in fact what what am I
trying to say in fact I should move I
only have a minute um yeah okay let me
let me put pressure on this guy here
this bishop the giant pest now that he
is definitely a giant passed maybe I
could induce some weaknesses here get
this pawn doing something else maybe my
king belongs somewhere else like here
just to defend this pawn and it stops
may be the potential for white to maybe
cut off my King more long term of course
step up one off of darks off of a dark
square though I don't really see this
bishop coming to life here I don't know
I definitely want to stay off dark maybe
I still want to capture this pawn one
day oh I could have landed a fork that's
another thing or I could have played
here and trapped the Queen that's what I
was talking about since the Rope went
back I had rook d2 is my opponent
listening are you listening if you're
listening what's the what's the three
words if you're listening that's oh why
you get hit with the soy actually I'm
not gonna do not here I was ready to hit
my opponent with the shame on you with
the shame on you
I know I am gonna go for this yeah
definitely I'm gonna go for a fork I
should have played rook there instead of
this ah okay as soon as the Rope went
back my opponent no longer had that
tactic and one of him beautiful wood
enough something you could see normally
like with the checkmate the knight and
rook imagine a king there that would be
checkmate on the
it was checkmate on the Queen in that
case alright well I missed my
opportunity early but things still look
pretty good here Queen takes pawn Knight
grabs a rook grabs a bishop the threat
the main one is to grab this rook and
then this Bishop the whole house the
whole farm is is out so I could grab
this pawn I'm not going to I think this
is the cleanest way just grab that and
then there's this Bishop is toast my
queen is uh she's in a strong strong
position so now I believe I just
threatened me g2 this is no issue the
bishops kind of dead that was my main
intention when I played c5 I was talking
earlier about trying to restrict this
Bishop he's about as restricted as you
can really being at that point alright
no time good game let me go back flip
this board and see about how either one
of us could have improved no I must say
that my decision to grab this night like
this I don't know that that is a good
thing to really be going with however
with Knight it will actually let me back
up for stepping why why am I saying the
decision to go with this right away is
maybe not a good idea I think it might
have something to do with this F Ponton
maybe still being able to get involved
in the game I don't know if I have much
fear if this F pawn can't get working
sometimes I've seen f-4e foreign just a
whole avalanche of pawns four pounds on
this fourth rank really starting to come
at black and really question the Knights
the night vs. Bishop decision that I
made by capturing on c3 or in other
words trying to say to black okay where
where are your Knights homes going to be
and I don't know that I could really
have a better home than f6 for this
Knight and if my opponent is allowed to
somehow we
that with the aid of this f-pawn if my
opponent is allowed to get in an e5
establish upon any five things are going
to be quite difficult for me this this
was not the case in the game because my
opponent did not have a pawn on e5 in
fact I was the one that had some space
by having a pawn on e4 but nevertheless
what I'm getting at is to try and
consider instead of the knight move and
by the way if you're if you're still
fixated on the nights before Bishop's
principle that's one that I just
absolutely
I just hate I don't I don't like that at
all I believe there's more exceptions to
that than anything I think retaining
this Knights options Bishop d3 with
moves like maybe even 92 to g3 are worth
considering or even f4 with tonight f3
I've seen this maneuver however I've
seen Bishop d3 I've seen night II to
keep this F pawns possibilities
available that's one thing and really a
main thing because what ends up
happening now is that I get this space
advantage and you're moving a piece for
a second time in things things
transition very quickly
efore c59 c6 stuff that's really what I
was wanting to get in I couldn't get to
this v square by way of c6 but d7 turns
out to be quite alright the idea to
challenge this pond I don't know if
you're really now there in time to have
this turn out to be good for you I'm
able to take and now this pawn is just
always a liability and I have control
over for it for as long as I'm able to
control either a 5 or better yet if I'm
able to control efore life is very
difficult for you and this Bishop in
particular is highlighted in a great way
so really it's a right out of the gates
where my main suggestion lies where
you bring out the knight to the
seemingly natural the very common f3
square but with this particular
structure consider something else like
Bishop d3 90 to keep this guy's options
open in short any other quick points I'm
not so sure I think black I don't know
that I gave you any opportunity to do to
do anything is this tough no matter
where he goes he's either biting at this
this rock on c5 or just staring at his
own upon or staring at his own pond here
so want one poorly placed piece or one
inactive piece couldn't really spoil the
whole game and he was he was an issue I
had some missed opportunities I did not
I did not play out here accurately all
the way through I had some missed
tactical opportunities as I was pointing
out along the way but my main points
were the F pawn right here considered
Bishop D through d3 and 92 okay
good game